butch à en terre encore ses morts
certains exhumés des fosses communes et
remises en terre une deuxième fois
d'autres retrouver là où ils ont été
tués par les soldats russes ça nous fait
beaucoup de
[Musique]
choses aujourd'hui
c'est mon ami mais c'est mon ami et il
[Musique]
a dit qu il est musulman victoria nous
explique des soldes a ordonné à son ami
de rentrer en courant chez lui et ils
ont tiré ils ont atteint de plusieurs
balles dans le dos et à la tête attaquer
komunicom personne dit elle n'avait le
droit d'aller chercher les corps pour
les enterrer le sien a été dévoré par
des chiens ou 10 boc ça c'est terrible
mais au bout de ce qu'ils sont que des
annonces font ça makhoul vire au trône
au clip promo saint aubin pour le maire
de la ville les exactions des russes ne
font aucun doute
ces citoyens ont été torturés violés
exécutés et selon lui c'était planifié
on était vraiment sonné salomé
l'automobile a
perdu
près de l'église où avaient été enterrés
à la hâte certaines des victimes dans
une fosse commune le silence est pesant
même s'il ne reste que quelques traces
du drame qui s'est pas six
depuis c'est à la morne que se poursuit
le minutieux travail d'enquêté sont de
possibles crimes de guerre des experts
identifient les victimes et détermine
les causes de leur mort pour
éventuellement traduire les responsables
en justice
ce n'est qu'après un long processus que
les corses ont finalement remis aux
familles
mais certains cherchent encore leurs
proches cet homme vient chaque jour
vérifier les listes dans l'espoir d'y
trouver le nom de son frère ce 12
octobre ça fait mal dit-il mars camors
doigt est enterrée c'est très dur pour
sa femme encore rien malheureusement
aujourd'hui board and reviendra demain
plus loin dans les rues de boudhha les
combats ont été terribles la brutalité
des forces russes particulièrement
visible dans cette rue qu'on appelle ici
la rue de la mort
parmi les corps découverts après le
retrait des russes il y avait tout au
bout de la rue celui du mari d'irina
abramova des soldats tchétchènes selon
elle ont lancé une grenade sur sa maison
et son mari voulait juste essayé
d'éteindre les flammes saad hariri avait
été tué le père ce vaisseau ils n'ont
pas voulu le laisser faire dit elle ils
ont amené devant l'ont fait agenouiller
lui enlever son chandail et ils l'ont
abattu
irina voulait mourir elle aussi mais
elle a tenu malgré sa peur malgré sa
peine parce qu'elle voulait récupérer le
corps de son mari laissés dans la rue
pendant un mois et le maître décemment
en terre
rihanna jay si je devenais près ce n'est
pas ce que je souhaite est telle
qu'aucun des soldats venus ici ne
repartent chez lui vivant
un sentiment de haine qui est partagée
par beaucoup au cimetière ou quatre
autres personnes étaient enterrées lors
de notre passage
pourquoi les russes les antilles tuer se
demande victoria il n'était pas armé il
ne menaçait personne c'était juste des
civils je déteste et tous les gens de
mon pays de test elle parle des russes
bien sûr et avant de partir victorien
nous demandent de bien montrer tout ça
pour que le monde sache ce qu'ils font
dans son pays
[Musique]
céline galipeau radio-canada à bout de
champ on écrit
[Musique]